foreign
[Music]
but the community is not yet perfected
in this it's self-consciousness in
general its content exists for it in the
form of picture thinking and The Duality
in this thinking still attaches even to
the actual spirituality of the community
to its return out of its picture
thinking just as the element of pure
thought itself was burdened with it
the community also does not possess the
consciousness of what it is it is
spiritual self-consciousness which is
not an object to itself as this
self-consciousness or what which does
not unfold itself to a consciousness of
itself but rather insofar as it is
consciousness it has those picture
thoughts which we have considered we see
self-consciousness at its last Turning
Point become inward to itself and attain
to a knowledge of its inwardness we see
it divest itself of its natural
existence and acquire pure negativity
but the positive meaning that is that
this negativity or pure inwardness of
knowledge is just as much the
self-identical essence or in other words
that substance has here succeeded in
becoming absolute self-consciousness
this is an other for the devotional
Consciousness it grasps this aspect that
is that the pure inwardization of
knowledge is in itself absolute
Simplicity or substance as the picture
thought of something which is so not in
virtue of its notion but it has the deed
of an alien satisfaction in other words
it does not grasp the fact that this
depth of the pure self is the power by
which the abstract Divine being is drawn
down from its abstraction and raised to
Itself by the power of this pure
devotion
the action of the self retains towards
it this negative meaning because the
externalization the kenosis of substance
is taken by the self to be an action
implicit in the nature of substance the
self does not grasp and truly comprehend
it or does not find it in its own action
as such
this Unity of essence and the self
having been implicitly achieved
Consciousness too still has this picture
thought of its reconciliation but as a
picture thought it obtains Satisfaction
by externally attaching to its pure
negativity the positive meaning of the
unity of itself with the essential being
its satisfaction thus itself remains
burdened with the antithesis of a Beyond
its own reconciliation therefore enters
its Consciousness as something distant
as something in the distant future just
as the reconciliation which The Other
Self achieved appears as something in
the distant past just as the individual
Divine man has a father in principle and
only an actual mother so too the
universal Divine man the community hands
for its father its own doing and knowing
but for its mother eternal love which it
only feels but does not behold in its
Consciousness as an actual immediate
object it's reconciliation therefore is
in its heart but its Consciousness is
still divided against itself and its
actual World Is Still disrupted
what enters its Consciousness as the in
itself or the side of pure mediation is
a Reconciliation that lies in the Beyond
but what enters it as present as the
side of immediacy in existence is the
world which still has to await its
Transfiguration
the world is indeed implicitly
reconciled with the Divine being and
regarding the Divine being it is known
of course that it recognizes the object
as no longer alienated from it but is
identical with it in its love
but for self-consciousness this
immediate presence
still has not the shape of spirit the
spirit of the community is thus in its
immediate Consciousness divided from its
religious Consciousness which declares
it is true that in themselves they are
not divided but this merely implicit
Unity is not realized or has not yet
become an equally absolute being for
self
with paragraph 787 we're now finishing
up the religion section the second to
last portion of the phenomenology and we
are very close to the end because we
have only the very short absolute
knowing section now to go through and
we're crossing a threshold into it so
we've surveyed all of this development
in the past you know there's the preface
of the introduction but what really
matters for the religion section is the
Consciousness the self-consciousness the
reason and spirit sections which we saw
early on are coming together like
threads being drawn into a knot now
we're finally at the end of this
penultimate section and this is a long
paragraph there's a good bit going on
here but we should think of this as a
sort of
summarization and a bringing together of
all of these previous themes so he
begins by invoking this notion of
community gaminda which we've been
developing both in the revealed religion
section and in the earlier sections he
says it's not yet perfected that is full
ended it's not brought to its fruition
yet in its self-consciousness it has
been brought to fruition in
Consciousness as we can see but not
fully as self-consciousness so he tells
us
what's wrong well in general it's
content it's in halt exists for it in
the form of picture thinking of four
stellen representation as we've talked
about for so long we don't need to
rehearse with the difference between
picture thinking or that's many
different uh synonyms and it's uh
opposition to something greater than it
and we saw that the community still does
use picture thinking right in the
previous paragraphs that we've surveyed
so he says that the The Duality the uh
you know being doubled in this in its
thinking still attaches to the actual
spirituality the spirit of the community
actual here is vehicle right so the we
could say to invoke something he's going
to talk about a little bit later worldly
the present
Spirit of the community is present to
itself and through itself through
representation so he says that it
attaches to the spirituality of the
community to its return out of its
picture thinking and he says just as the
element of pure thought itself was
burdened with it and this is a this is a
word that Hegel is going to use several
times in this period of being burdened
being Laden down with being you could
say
uh conditioned or determined or made
particular by it in such a way that
doesn't allow it to completely reach its
fruition
so he goes on and he says the community
also does not possess the consciousness
of what it is and here he's going to
tell us what it is all he's going to
tell us more as we move into absolute
knowing where the community is going to
be the locus of where we discover
ourselves and find our full recognition
so what is it missing what doesn't it
get he says it is spiritual
self-consciousness right guy sticker
voice which is not an object to itself
as now notice this very important
qualifier this self-consciousness it is
present to itself as we've seen
previously
as self-consciousness it grasps itself
as self-consciousness but not as this
self-consciousness
what self-consciousness are we talking
about here so he says um
which does not unfold itself to a
consciousness of itself but
insofar as it is consciousness it has
those picture thoughts which we have
considered right those picture thoughts
which we have been discussing this
entire time so what picture thoughts are
we thinking about
well you know a little bit later in here
he's going to talk about the you know
Divine human being that's Jesus in this
story that spans going back into you
know the fall of human beings and all of
these struggles of the people of God and
then a messiah being sent to them but
you know as a little baby rather that
has you know this Warrior who's going to
restore everything and then the teaching
and uh you know this reconciliation
between human and God through this
person and then his his death the death
of God and the resurrection the
resurrection not just of him but of the
community all of this is part of the
story right and there could be many
other parts of it all of those are
matters of representation
so he goes on
and he tells us that we see
self-consciousness at its last Turning
Point
become inward to itself and attain to a
knowledge of its inwardness and this is
a very important Point as well and this
is not something unique to the religion
section
self-consciousness human
self-consciousness you know exists in
relation to other self-consciousnesses
but it has an interiority and we've been
talking about this the entire time
people are always like well what is the
for itself for Hegel is it just pure
negativity of the in itself no that's
John Paul sart who is you know working
with these categories inwardness the in
the game that we've been talking about
the going into itself or withdrawal into
itself this is actually quite important
he's not saying this so much uh
explicitly here but this is going to be
tied in with devotional Consciousness
that is going to take us beyond the
devotional consciousness of the unhappy
Consciousness which could only see
itself as
something lacking something lesser in
relation to a
Eternal that is in the great yanzites
the beyond that we're also going to see
discussed here in this passage as well
here the human being in the community
the community of of belief and action
and thinking attains an inwardness to
itself
grasping itself as a human being with an
interiority to itself right
and so we go on and he says it attains
to its knowledge of this inwardness we
see it divest itself of its natural
existence and acquire pure negativity
what's your natural existence well in my
case what you are actually seeing right
here in front of you this body which is
determinate which has you know age and
gender and all sorts of other markers
that we can talk about a certain height
how tall am I about this taller it
doesn't tell you anything right that's a
meaningless thing for me to do but it's
kind of a interesting joke nonetheless
but it does you know it does measure for
myself
you know when I put my hand on my head
like that so you know the question is
well who who is this person who Am I who
who is the person of the religious
community is it just what we see the
determinants of ourselves in our social
existence within the community how we're
marked or is there a negativity within
every single one of us
that possesses as we saw all the way
back in the preface of power right of
negativity of of being able to be other
this is what part of what makes us human
is that we are negativity even in
all of this development all of this
complicated growth
we still remain free and that's part of
the negativity
so he goes on
and he says the positive meaning
of this that this negativity or pure
inwardness of notice what he says
knowledge
is just as much the
self-identical essence the Vasan right
that is related to itself or in other
words and this goes back to some of the
developments that were taking place in
this this section right let me pause for
a moment and let's remind ourselves we
got a lot of s words in English and
mostly in German also floating around
right we've got self-consciousness we
have subject we have self right this
reflexivity of things the this identity
of things and then we also have
substance so sub subject substance uh
self self-consciousness all of these
things are connected to each other as we
have witnessed before and he says
substance has here succeeded
in becoming
absolute self-consciousness now
typically when we think about a
substance and we've talked about this
many times in other paragraph
commentaries we think of something that
may be dynamic but is in a certain sense
lacking
intentional agency right that's you need
to have self in order to have that or be
a subject substance by itself
you know it it lasts it perdures through
time it may even do things like a tree
could be a substance an Aristotelian
sense uh you know hagel's Acorn and Oak
right from the preface but
it's only when it actually becomes
self-consciousness
that the substance realizes makes
vehicle
what the possibilities of substance are
we are substances right
we as members of the community
are substances connected with other
substances other self-consciousnesses
within the spiritual community
so he goes on
and he says
that uh
it succeeded in becoming absolute
self-consciousness so absolute here
doesn't just mean like taken to its
furthest extent I mean it isn't taken to
its furthest extent right because it's
not full-ended as we saw at the
beginning of the paragraph absolute here
means
connecting everything together right the
product of all these sublations the term
by the way which he doesn't use here he
doesn't use auf Haven or Alpha hoben he
uses air hoben over and over again for
raising up in this this uh
paragraph So he goes on and he says that
um
here we go the substance is becoming
succeeded in becoming absolute
self-consciousness this
absolute self-consciousness and here
this shows you why it's not reached its
its full ending it's Perfection it's
finalization
um it is an other an Honduras
four and here Hagel is going to use an
important term the devotional
Consciousness
devotional on dectica right
um later on he's going to talk about
undocked devotion so we've got these two
things going on here and what does this
mean so when we talk about being devoted
or devotions that has a typically
religious
sort of connotation so you do your
devotions like maybe if you're a
Catholic you say the rosary which is a
whole number of prayers that are counted
by using you know these beads and then
you meditate upon various Mysteries and
you know it can get kind of complicated
and people introduce all sorts of other
things but that's a good example of a
devotional
um saying grace before meals right
praying over the food that you're going
to have
um whether it's a you know regular same
thing every single time prayer or it's
extemporaneous it's devotional and these
are actually good examples because
they're not just like purely throwing
your words or prayers up there to God or
something like that there's some sort of
physicality some sort of
actuality in hegelian terms vehicle kite
that is involved and it is you you who
is doing it so the devotional
Consciousness this is the religious
Consciousness but engaging itself
towards something else and notice that
he's saying here that the devotional
consciousness
it's not it's not getting everything
it's still using picture thought or
representation there's still
bifurcations there's still
dichotomies to use the earlier word that
he was using there is a duality that
needs to be overcome so he he goes on
and he says yet meaning the devotional
Consciousness grasps this aspect that
the pure inward inwardization right
going inside of itself of knowledge is
in itself absolute Simplicity or
substance as the picture thought of
something which is so and then he says
not in virtue of its notion it's because
right of the concept
so not grasping it that way but grasping
it through picture thinking
but as the deed the doing the hand lung
in this case
of a alien
satisfaction finders right and hegel's
using a couple different
um
terms here that we translate as
satisfaction or satisfying right and
this is going to play an important role
why do we care about satisfaction well
that's what we're aiming for right you
know we saw all the way back in the
self-consciousness section that human
being as self-consciousness is begierda
desire hunger desire for what for
something that will genuinely satisfy it
and you know we've gone through all
sorts of interesting Transformations
maybe it could be dominating another
self-consciousness or enjoying the
fruits of it the Lord and the master
maybe it could be being in touch with
the The Good the rational the true you
know stoicism maybe it's just tearing
things down skepticism maybe it's
reaching out to that Eternal you know
beyond unhappy Consciousness all these
other things in the reason section all
these other things in the spirit section
all sorts of matters can be
potential satisfactions
religion has its own satisfactions so he
goes on and he tells us it doesn't grasp
the fact that this depth of the pure
self is the power by which the abstract
Divine being God is drawn down from its
abstraction and raised to a self by the
power once again of this pure devotion
highness undoct right
we make God what God is in part for
Hegel by what we do with God so he goes
on and he says the action of the self
retains towards it this negative meaning
why because the externalization
the kenosis now kenosis is a theological
term not there in the German typically
means an emptying it's coming from Greek
right and it's used as part of Christian
theology is it wrong no but Miller is
being periphrastic here he's trying to
like you know signal to us that we're
talking about you know Christianity so
the kenosis of substance is taken by the
self to be an action a comportment
implicit in the nature of substance the
self he says
does not grasp and truly comprehend it
or does not find it in its own action as
such so the self the religious
community and the people within it are
not yet getting that they are the ones
doing what's being done they're still
thinking in terms of themselves
and a God who is different than them
right even if the God lives inside their
heart or stuff like that
so he's going to tell us about how this
framework Works in a bit but he goes on
and he says
this Unity of essence and the self
having been implicitly achieved notice
hegel's always talking about well this
was implicitly done now we need to move
to the explicit implicitly achieve
Consciousness too still has this picture
thought
of its reconciliation right so
um
reconciliation yeah I did spell it
correctly this is a really important
term uh throughout the rest of this
paragraph This is what religion has been
aiming at right this is what the whole
process aims at reconciliation bringing
things together that seem to be in
Conflict seem to be opposed to each
other that seem not to fit but uh we
don't have a true reconciliation here we
don't have a conceptual reconciliation
we have the picture thought the the
imagination the representation of
reconciliation
so he says we have this you know as a
picture thought it obtains Satisfaction
by externally attaching to its pure
negativity the positive meaning of the
unity of itself with the essential being
so we're still in a duality God us
essential Unity but we're still distinct
from each other because it's in picture
thinking
and here he's going to say something
really interesting
it's satisfaction right
remains burdened with what
with the antithesis of a Beyond now
I've mentioned many times that that
Miller uses this word antithesis in a
kind of fast and loose way sometimes it
is translating things that are merely
opposed to each other you know and gagan
zets and sometimes it is translating
um you know other terms as well that
that represent opposition
sometimes it's translating what it is
here
giganzatz contradiction it's not just
antithesis antithesis it is a full
contradiction right so that is quite
important to Signal here
um a contradiction of what a
contradiction of the Beyond of the Yan
zites where did we encounter that
well you know back when we also talked
about religion in the unhappy
Consciousness right so we have to be
very careful not to slip back into that
and to make some progress here so he
says its own reconciliation
enters its Consciousness is something
distant at phosphereus right fan is
something that is at a distance right so
what are the modalities of this he's
going to talk about a distant past
and a distant future
literally it's not a distant past it's a
distance of the past fairness deaf gong
and height right and it's not a distant
future it's a distance of the future
fairness there zukunt and what do we
have here something that is represented
something that is imagined rather than
experienced he says its own
reconciliation enters its Consciousness
as something distant adds something in
the distant future just as the
reconciliation which The Other Self
achieved appears as something in the
distant past and then he's got this very
interesting like little you know musing
here an analogy he says just as the
individual Divine man who's that Jesus
right had a father in principle and only
an actual vehicleic mother Mary is the
actual human being who Bears Jesus the
theotokos the god Bearer and you know
the Holy Spirit overshadows or whatever
the hell that means right and Hegel
wants us to figure out what things mean
so what corresponds to the father and to
the mother in this case he tells us that
so too the universal Divine man and now
notice what he's going to say here it is
very quick equation so to the universal
Divine man the community
no longer an individual the community
has for its father what its own doing
and knowing
how can you be your own father well a
community can right because it's
generational it continues on and on and
on its own doing its own knowing and
these are intimately connected for Hegel
right the Practical and the theoretical
so it's got a a it's a father to itself
and then there's the mother what's the
mother in this case
eternal love which it only feels but
does not behold in its Consciousness as
an actual in immediate object feeling
full for Hegel is lesser than
representation which of course is lesser
than conceptual thought so he goes on
and he says it's reconciliation
therefore is in its heart
right so there is a Reconciliation ready
for us
but its Consciousness is still divided
against itself and its actual World Is
Still disrupted
what enters its Consciousness as the in
itself or the side of pure mediation is
a Reconciliation that lies in the beyond
what Beyond
the distant future or the distant past
but not right here and now not yet
so he says what enters it is present
as the side of immediacy right so the
present is the gag envirate you know
which is being here opposed to the past
and the future and position between them
is mediating uh immediacy right when
mitzelbachite and existence is what the
world
the world that we live in the world that
we act in the world that we think in the
world that we represent in the world in
which the community exists throughout
time and he says it's the world which
still has to await its Transfiguration
so everything's not done yet
he says the world is indeed implicitly
reconciled with the Divine being and
regarding the Divine being it is known
of course that it recognizes the object
as no longer alienated from it you know
distanced from it but identical with it
in its love so you'll notice he's
bringing up love once again here but
love is still at the point of it being a
Feeling
for self-consciousness he says this
immediate presence of the world that is
reconciled to God
is not still has not yet the shape of
spirit so he tells us to conclude here
the spirit of the community is in its
immediate Consciousness divided it from
its religious Consciousness which
declares that in themselves they are not
divided but this merely implicit Unity
is not realized has not become an
equally absolute being for self we've
got a lot of stuff going on here we've
got a lot of stuff that's been achieved
here but a lot of it is still you could
say on paper implicit it hasn't been
brought out completely does that mean
that it's not any good no and and to not
be completely fulfilled doesn't mean
that you haven't gotten like three
quarters of the way there or perhaps you
know 7 8 or whatever we want
but it still has more to develop
that's where we're going in the next
section so now we've we've seen what
religion and religion as a culmination
of all these other movements can
actually get us to and notice let me
close on this
this happens
in the community this does not happen
with the isolated philosophical
individual in the proverbial Ivory Tower
totally you know separated from
everybody else figuring out what the
real meaning of the scriptures is or
activities or stuff like that no it's
got to happen in relation to the rest of
the members of the community it's it's
got to be something where we all come
along on this not just the sage not just
the you know brilliant philosopher but
everything is supposed to transform
into philosophy